[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour cette édition spéciale consacrée au
décès de la reine d'angleterre elizabeth
ii qui s'est éteinte hier après midi
dans son château de balmoral en écosse à
l'âge de 96 ans après 70 ans de règne le
plus long règne de l'histoire du
royaume-uni charles est donc le nouveau
roi d'angleterre sous le nom de charles
iii et pendant 1h30 on va revenir sur la
vie d'elizabeth de son règne son
empreinte sa relation avec la france et
ses territoires qu'elle appréciait tant
la tour eiffel c'est d'ailleurs éteinte
cette nuit pour lui rendre hommage et ce
matin la reine d'angleterre est à la une
de tous vos quotidiens régionaux nous
ferons le tour de nos régions avec la
presse régionale pendant cette émission
on sera en bretagne en champagne dans le
centre de la france dans le sud ouest
vous verrez que dans chaque région la
reine a marqué son empreinte et pour
commencer cette émission nous sommes
avec deux sénateurs céline boulay
speroni bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes la vice présidente
du groupe d'amitié france royaume-uni si
le sénat vous connaissez bien sûr très
bien le royaume uni on va en parler avec
vous et puis olivier cadic vous êtes
avec nous en duplex merci également
d'être avec nos sénateurs de les
français de l'étranger vous vivez à
londres vous nous direz ce que la reine
représenter pour l'angleterre et pour
les anglais et l'angleterre qui est
évidemment plongé dans la tristesse ce
matin avant de vous entendre on va
regarder ce portrait de la reine
elizabeth ii et les signaux très vieux
thann et gaspard flammes il est 19
heures 40 en france quand de l'autre
côté de la manche la bbc interrompt ses
programmes le présentateur vêtus de noir
prononce les mots que tous les
britanniques redoute parking on
travaille le palais de buckingham vient
d'annoncer la mort de sa majesté la
reine elizabeth 2 la reine s'est éteinte
dans l'après midi à l'âge de 96 ans dans
son château privé de balmoral en écosse
entourée de sa famille proches dont ses
quatre enfants celui qui est encore à ce
moment là le prince charles la princesse
anne et les princes andrew et edward les
médecins de la reine avait alerté sur
son état de santé préoccupant
c'est par un tweet que la famille royale
annonce officiellement son décès la
reine est morte paisiblement à balmoral
cet après midi
elle aura régné un peu plus de soixante
dix ans sur le royaume uni un record de
longévité pour un monarque britannique
en juin dernier elle célébrait
d'ailleurs son jubilé de platine l'une
des dernières apparitions publiques
entouré de la famille royale et de tous
ces sujets une vie au service de la
monarchie en 1952 à la suite du décès de
son père le roi george 6 la princesse
elisabeth devient la reine elizabeth 2
sous les yeux des caméras à tout juste
25 ans elle aura vu défiler pas moins de
quinze premiers ministres de winston
churchill au milieu du xxème siècle ali
strauss qu'elle a rencontré mardi
dernier elisabeth deux incarner pour
beaucoup la stabilité inébranlable
malgré les crises 8 britannique sur dix
disait apprécier son action et ce malgré
des périodes plus sombres après la mort
de la princesse diana en 1997 la reine a
attendu cinq jours pour s'exprimer
publiquement expliquant avoir voulu
protéger ses petits enfants une attitude
que la population lui a alors reproché
l'histoire de la reine d'angleterre est
aussi intimement liée à celle de son
mari le prince philip celui qu'elle
considérait comme son rauque et son
soutien elle a accompagné et conseillé
tout au long de leurs 70 ans de vie
commune la reine lui avait fait ses
adieux en avril 2021 après le décès de
sa mère le prince charles a décrit un
moment de grande tristesse il devient
désormais le roi charles iii chargé de
régner sur le royaume uni et le
commonwealth
de rennes quelle a été votre réaction
hier en approbation des faits j'étais
triste j'étais triste d'abord ge des
grands amis dans le peuple anglais
j'étais en empathie avec eux je sais à
quel point ils étaient attachés à leur
reine c'était le ciment du peuple
britannique elle incarnait vraiment le
britannique c'était la grande bretagne
et c'était ce symbole d'unité qui a
traversé les époques avec cette
longévité extraordinaire qui est presque
anachronique aujourd'hui où le monde est
en proie à des divisions
à des stratégies de communication à des
changements elle elle incarnait cette
stabilité
avec toujours ce sérieux
[Musique]
cette humilité surtout cette stabilité
et ce sens du devoir qui dépasse les
stratégies de communication et qui
d'ailleurs touche toute la famille
royale très souvent on a parlé du fait
qu'elle aurait pu se destituer au profit
de charles qui attendaient depuis des
années de régner et bien non elle a
assumé jusqu'au dernier moment son rôle
de reine rappelez vous son discours
d'intronisation lorsqu à 25 ans elle
devient jaune règne et qu'elle explique
que que sa vie soit longues qu'elles
soient courtes jusqu'à son dernier
souffle elle sera le monarque
britannique qu'elle a été elle a tenu
parole jusqu'au dernier moment c'est en
tout point admirable ouais on va revenir
évidemment sur sa vie olivier cadic vous
quel a été votre réaction rappelle que
vous viviez au royaume uni dans le kent
on imagine que ça a été une émotion
particulière pour vous
évidemment je suis juillet au royaume
uni depuis 25 ans maintenant et que
comme tout le monde j'ai été très
attristé par cette nouvelle la
disparition de la reine elizabeth ii
laisse personne indifférent bien sûr on
savait qu'elle était très diminué il ya
trois jours à peine elle recevait la
nouvelle première ministre li strauss à
balmoral il lui était impossible de
revenir au palais de buckingham donc
c'était quand même un signe important
l'annoncé de son décès hier a malgré
tout été une surprise à un vrai choc
pour tout le monde le royaume uni leur
sa reine
mais c'est aussi un voile de tristesse
par le dock est ce qu'elle représentait
les abattent deux pour le peuple
britannique
s'est
elle incarne la résilience des
britanniques face à l'adversité
c'était la dignité en toutes
circonstances
et je crois qu'elle conservera à jamais
qu'une place dans l'imaginaire collectif
britannique ils ont une profonde
affection pour leur souveraine et
certains vivent ce départ comme un
traumatisme
un deuil familial on ressent avec les
les échanges qu'on peut avoir avec
certains aient vraiment jeu profitait de
l'occasion pour adresser toute ma
sympathie toute ma solidarité
le britannique car ils vivent même si
c'était attendu ils vivent une vraie
preuve avec ce départ de une personne
qui va rester comme il l'est jaune les
britanniques que vous connaissez bien au
delà d'avoir perdu leur souveraine ils
ont le sentiment d'avoir perdu une mère
une grand mère
c'est ça c'est hydro vous savez tous un
rapport avec avec la reine c'est un
règne qui a duré 70 ans donc vous
imaginez est là elle s'en va à l'âge de
96 ans donc pratiquement tous les
britanniques sont nés en connaissant la
reine elizabeth ii joie qui a donc dans
le coeur de chaque britannique la reine
c'est un rapport à la tradition
la couronne c'est le signe de la
continuité nationale mais elle a aussi
accompagner le changement la modernité
est d'ailleurs la première ministre hier
soir liste rust rappelé dans son
allocution que la reine était un roc sur
lequel la grande bretagne moderne a été
fondé puis je pense aussi aux propos du
président de la république qui a rendu
hommage à une reine de coeur qui a
marqué à jamais son pays son siècle il a
tout à fait raison
mais aussi que la reine était également
une amie de la france et ça c'est
peut-être un message qui devrait
inspirer la nouvelle première ministre
et maire va revenir évidemment sur sur
cette déclaration des manuels mâcon mais
sur elizabeth 2 c'était un lien
évidemment affectif entre elles et les
britanniques olivier cadic disaient les
abete 2 c'est aussi là le royaume uni
moderne est-ce que c'est aussi la place
du royaume uni dont le monde et les
abbés deux skis si le royaume uni on est
là dans monde c'est grâce à elle elle
est l'une des personnalités les plus
connues mais de tout l'évidence il ya
une spécificité britannique il suffisait
de voir moi j'ai été très touché par
l'aspect il annonce du journaliste de la
bbc hier qui incarnait vraiment ce deuil
et on sentait tout le deuil du peuple
britannique
à travers ce journaliste de la bbc la
bbc vous savez qu'il y avait été
omniprésente lors de son couronnement et
faisait rentrer d'une certaine manière
avec son couronnement sept jeunes am la
grande bretagne dans la modernité déjà
rappelez vous qu elle s'est imposée dans
un monde d'hommes qu'elle avait tout la
première guerre mondiale qu'elle
conduisait des camions parce qu'elle
était sous lieutenant dans l'armée
terrestre et qu'elle est venue avec son
mari que son couronnement soit télévisé
soit et l'ambiance idéale et voit une
forme de modernité elle fait rentrer son
couronnement dans les foyers des
britanniques donc non seulement elle est
incarnée mais il ya ce lien fusionnel
entre le peuple britannique et la reine
est bien évidemment ce rayonnement dans
le monde et d'ailleurs l'émotion
aujourd'hui elle est mondiale et tous
les chefs d'état c'était un chef d'état
beer endommagée on sent cette émotion
palpable qui n'a rien du tout
d'anecdotique ou de du ressort de la
midinette rit bien au contraire elle est
vraiment très très sérieuse très
ressenti cette émotion c'est elle qui a
donné olivier cadic sa place
particulière au royaume uni dans le
monde de par sa personnalité
face au destin elle a toujours été
exemplaire elle a incarné les valeurs
morales la résilience de tout un peuple
est très jeune ma collègue céline l'a
appelée et elle a une conscience aiguë
son rôle d'aider son premier discours et
en 1940 elle avait 14 ans seulement elle
a prononcé un discours à la bbc c'était
pour donner courage aux enfants devenus
orphelins ou qui devaient être évacuées
pour fuir les bombardements à londres et
déjà elle était parfaite sincère et elle
le disait je suis avec vous on parle de
modernité par effectivement le fait que
son mariage avaient été télévisées mais
c'est jusque dans la manière d'annoncer
son départ par un tweet c'est ça montre
qu'elle a été elle a tout suivi toute
cette évolution
elle et elle incarne quelque chose de
très profond
elle incarne aussi on disait on va en
parler l'unité l'unité du royaume uni la
reine d'angleterre est décédé dans son
château de balmoral en écosse au moment
où les causses connais mes velléités
d'indépendance est ce qu'on peut voir
une signification à ce décès en terre
écossaise
je crois que je crois que non c'est ça
pas de rapports lâche
je crois que la reine a quand même
toujours incarné justement cette unité
du royaume c'est
maintenant la grande bretagne l'école
fait partie de la grande bretagne le
royaume uni c'est le royaume uni de
grande bretagne et d'irlande du nord
elle incarne cette unité maintenant elle
a vécu aussi ce démembrement quand on
voit ce que représentait le royaume uni
quand elle est devenue reine est ce que
c'est aujourd'hui effectivement avec ses
menace d'implosion dans la dans le
prolongement du bric site effectivement
elle mais elle a toujours su incarner
quand même 7 cette union donc là
aujourd'hui je pense que la
problématique est différente c'est
rendre hommage tout le monde est dans
l'émotion rendre hommage à cette
personnalité exceptionnelle qui nous
aura tous marqués et est aujourd'hui je
crois que tout le monde est concentré là
dessus
moi je pense sincèrement qu'on y voit le
signal qu'on a envie d'y voir et je
pense que c'est très symptomatique comme
moment même de sa mort on se pose cette
question là il faut rappeler que
l'angleterre traverse une triple crise
assez exceptionnel l'angleterre et
rentrer en récession il ya une crise
économique il ya une crise politique et
de fait une crise sociale et c'est
symbole d'unité incarné par la reine va
peut-être aller au delà de son décès
certes en tout cas ce qui est en train
de se passer et on peut y voir le
symbole qu'on souhaite et je trouve ça
symptomatique est intéressante est
personnellement
ce royaume uni peut-être atténuer ses
velléités d'indépendance sur certains à
côté en tout cas par exemple sur la
famille royale on voit qu'elle l'a réuni
temporairement autour d'elle on espère
que ça va durer on a quelques craintes
là dessus mais le symbole de la famille
royale étant le symbole de toute la
nation on peut espérer que en tout cas
cela jouera sur la crise avec écosse oui
effectivement cette famille ait fini son
reine elizabeth ii avec une
extraordinaire popularité pourtant elle
a connu évidemment 70 ans de rennes des
hauts des bas aussi bien sur le plan
politique sur le plan personnel avec
peut-être un simple un symptôme en 1997
au moment de la mort de lady di ou là la
monarchie a quelque peu vaciller la
monarchie a pu montrer à un moment
qu'elle avait pris des distances
peut-être bien involontaire avec le
peuple lady diana était la princesse du
peuple on a vu toutes les réactions je
pense que peut-être que la reine à ce
moment là n'avait pas mesuré mais ça a
duré de trois jours elle s'est rattrapé
ensuite en faisant un discours
d'ailleurs assez émouvant et je me
rappelle des commentaires à l'époque qui
disaient qu'elle était dans son rôle et
qu'elle était jamais vraiment sorti de
sa réserve et cinq jours après elle
avait montré en descendant dans la rue
d'ailleurs y avait des images très
fortes où elle avait été à la rencontre
du peuple ce qui montrait qu'elle savait
évoluer aussi et évoluer rapidement et
quand cinq jours après à la fesse
discours finalement les britanniques lui
ont pardonné donc c'était en 70 ans de
règne il y a eu un ou deux événements ou
les britanniques on peut lui en vouloir
mais ça a duré quelques jours voilà en
70 ans de règne alors que vous avez des
hommes politiques aujourd'hui qui
traverse crise sur crise et c'est ça qui
est assez intéressant olivier cadic en
70 ans de règne il n'y a jamais eu une
rupture finalement entre elizabeth ii et
son peuple
quand une fois ce qu'est ce qu'elle
représente
est tellement profond donc c'est li na
rézon quelques une réaction
incomprise au moment de lui décès
accidentel de lady di a été très vite
surmontées moi ce qui m'a vraiment le
plus marqué ça aura été l'ouverture des
jeux olympiques à londres il ya tout
juste dix ans et quand on parle de
modernité qui pouvait imaginer de voir
la reine partir avec james bond monter
dans un hélicoptère
et puis arrivée dans le stade pour
lancer des jeux olympiques c'est c'était
toujours un clin d'oeil fantastique
le savez se mettre vraiment tout le
temps en proximité avec les britanniques
c'est sur le lien personnel faut
imaginer quand un britannique allait à
une garden party à buckingham moi j'en
ai connu quelques-uns qui qui allait
c'était l'événement il avait ne
serait-ce que un instant croiser le
regard de la reine eu un échange je
dirais de quelques secondes il revenait
de ça comme s'il avait vécu le grand
moment de leur existence c'était sait il
faut vraiment la rencontre et les
britanniques et partager ces moments là
sentir leurs émotions pour comprendre ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui aucune profond
de leur être ouais ça une espagne elle a
su évoluer avec son temps évolué avec
son peuple évolue aussi avec les
nouveaux outils on se souvient de cette
vidéo assez drôle avec son petit-fils le
prince harry justement où elle sortait
un petit peu de sa réserve et c'était
une reine qu'on ne voyait pas jusque là
c'est aussi ça la force d'elizabeth ii
d'avoir su évoluer avec son peuple oui
tu évoluerez son peuple faire ce genre
on se souvient de la vidéo avec
paddington au moment du du jubilé avec
tout ce monde mais justement ces petits
événements qui on peut avoir lieu parce
qu'anne incarner cette stabilité ce
sérieux et et par conséquence et ses
petits événements ou au contraire montré
qu'elle pouvait être une reine moderne
sans toutefois écorné son image et c'est
ça qui a été intéressant et quand je
disais que c'était la tradition
perpétuelle au détriment des stratégies
de communication de l'instant elle
savait quand même un style et ses
petites radios de communication pour
montrer qu'elle était bien incarné dans
un bien bien installé dans son siècle
avec le peuple britannique et c'est ça
qui a été et qui a montré une grande
intelligence chez elle d'évolution
d'ailleurs on disait que c'était une une
très grande travailleuse beaucoup de
cultures très intelligente j'entendais
ce matin que les services de
renseignement britanniques l'ont rendue
au match qu'il ne faut en général jamais
il disait que tous les jours elle lisait
leur rapport ils s'informaient vraiment
constamment ce sont des choses que
peut-être on ignore puisque la
constitution fait qu'elle ne parlait
jamais mais elle avait une réelle
influence sur ce qui se passait en
grande bretagne elle avait un rôle bien
plus politique que ce que la condition
lui donne une politique qu'est ce que la
constitution lui donner chef d'état chef
du gouvernement je crois même mais c'est
ça qui est intéressant à voir à
décrypter je pense qu'il y aura beaucoup
de littérature à partir d'aujourd'hui on
pourra analyser tout ça et on vraiment
on n'a pas fini de le faire ouais
elisabeth de l'entreprise relation
particulière avec notre pays avec la
france les français étaient d'ailleurs
attaché à la reine ce matin elle est en
une de tous nos quotidiens régionaux on
va faire le tour des rédactions locales
justement dans cette édition spéciale on
commence en allant à rennes on retrouve
son mari rob un bon jour ils marient
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
journaliste à ouest-france ouest-france
qui bien évidemment fait sa une sur la
reine d'angleterre elizabeth ii elle
était the queen oui effectivement très
très proches géographiquement de la
grande bretagne ouest devait être
dans cette édition spéciale de quatre
pages dans laquelle nous pouvons admirer
d'ailleurs toutes les couleurs portées
par les souverains de dubé en une
doublure rouge en pages intérieures et
en dernière page nous racontons
évidemment les dernières heures
d'elizabeth ii et l'ambiance si spécial
régnant à londres en lien avec notre
correspondante sur place vous dresse
aussi un long portrait d' à s'ouvrir en
dernière page et puis et puis nous
parlons de charles iii 73 ans le futur
roi pour lequel le plus dur commence à
la tête du royaume en perte de vitesse à
l'international comme au royaume-uni
elizabeth ii a joué un rôle de ciment
fondamental pour la couronne l'îcone
quittant la scène ce ciment tiendra-t-il
s'interroge notre éditorialiste leurs
marchands ces défis qui attend son
successeur une épreuve de vérité pour
lequel pour l'unité du royaume fragile
et par le break site et la légitimité
même de pouvoir de l'institution
monarchique depuis hier soir vous l'avez
dit les hommages internationaux ce
pleuvent sur londres en prof notamment
provenance notamment de france dans
cette édition spéciale nous racontons
également comment il avait 2 a su
entretenir des relations d'amitié
privilégiés avec l'hexagone
et même vincent auriol et rené coty la
reine et la france qui le guérandais
bien elle est souvent venu à paris mais
aussi en touraine voir des châteaux de
la loire qu'elle admire et ans et puis
évidemment en amandine sur les plages du
débarquement
consacrant d'ailleurs un éclairage
particulier à ces séjours normands n y
étais chez zen françois mitterrand était
son chouchou - valéry giscard d'estaing
qu'elle jugeait trop snob pour emmanuel
macron le souffle la souveraine était le
fil d'or voilier à la france et
l'angleterre la preuve de l'amitié
indéfectible entre les deux nations le
pilote s'est toujours duquel six à
charles iii maintenant de leur guise et
pourrait effectivement être ça c'est à
lire dans ouest france ce matin quatre
pages spéciales consacrées à la reine
d'angleterre évidemment votre une convoi
elizabeth ii elle était the queen c'est
à la une de ouest france merci beaucoup
il marie robin d'un jaune est avec nos
oliviers qui a dit qu'elle était la
relation entre la reine et la france
je crois que
l'histoire moi j'ai dépanné mais
l'histoire nous apprend que son premier
voyage à l'étranger était pour la france
elle parlait français c'était la seule
langue étrangère qu'elle parlait si je
ne me trompe pas
c'est que beaucoup ont témoigné du fait
que l parler remarquablement français
elle est aussi celle qui aura inauguré
le tunnel sous la manche puisque moi je
bénéficie sans le tunnel je pourrais pas
vivre de cette façon à aller et venir
entre la france et le royaume uni de la
même manière donc c'est le la marque je
crois que c'est un peu un clin d'oeil
c'est elle a réalisé quelque chose qui
pouvait être kiki et relevait du rêve
puis finalement c'est elle qui a
inauguré le le tunnel sous la manche
je crois que vraiment c'est c'était une
amie de la france c'est le président de
la république l'a mis dans son message
d'hommage c'est tout à fait vrai c'est
ce que l'on ressentait et je me souviens
lorsqu'elle est venue la dernière fois à
paris en 2014 s'écrie à paris de vive la
reine quand elle je dirais quand elle
était sûre sur l'île saint louis ça ça
m'a beaucoup marqué ah que les les
français puis ve puisse un pays est
vraiment républicain puisse créer comme
ça avec autant de d'entousiasme
s'exclamer vive la reine
est ce qu'après une forme de paradoxe
est une boule est erronée de la part de
français qui ont coupé la tête de leroy
et qui adorait la reine d'angleterre
mais c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure c'est qu'elle va bien au delà
des symboles l1 car tellement encore
plus qu une royauté qu'une famille
royale qui a pu être décriée d'ailleurs
on voit la dichotomie entre la reine et
le reste de la famille royale qui somme
toute a des défauts souvent très humain
on n'a pas rappelé une chose mais son
état de santé aurait beaucoup décliné
depuis qu'elle a perdu son époux
donc c'était une mère une grand mère
c'était aussi une épouse et elle
incarner cette stabilité de couple avec
ce couple fusionnel
rock
rock elle était un roc elle s'appuyait
sur un roc et ce qu'ils a fait aussi sa
longévité et l'angleterre c'est souvent
le pays qu'on adore détester 1 mais sont
nos voisins à quelque part ce sont un
peu nos frères ennemis et elle a
toujours veillé à ce que finalement les
relations soient fluidifier entre la
france et l'angleterre elle prenait
toujours la parole en français elle
avait un français excellent et quand
elle disait ses discours en français
elle montrait
la carnet de l'amitié qu'elle voulait
montrer avec la france et elle s'est
rendue à plusieurs reprises en france
dont une fois en 2004 au sénat et on va
voir ça oui avec canton chalmé qui nous
rejoint bonjour quand un bon jour vous
allez m'accompagner tout au long de
cette édition spéciale évidemment et
vous avait replongé pour nous dans les
archives du sénat en 2004 la reine
elizabeth ii se rend en france pour sa
quatrième visite d'état et a les reçus
au sénat voilà quatrième visite d'état
sur cinq au total qu'elle a réalisés
dans le pays effectivement et c'est un
souvenir on peut dire qu'il est resté
dans l'esprit de nombreux journalistes
de la chaîne un des grands événements de
l'époque pour public sénat la reine qui
est arrivé en rolls dans la cour
d'honneur du sénat accueilli à l'époque
par christian poncelet qui était le
président du du de la chambre haute est
également jean louis debré à ses côtés
qui lui présidait l'assemblée nationale
elles venaient commémorer en 2004 les
100 ans de l'entente cordiale l'accord
destiné à aplanir les différends
coloniaux qu'il y avait entre la france
et le royaume uni l'accord qui était
donc signé en avril
1904 à l'appui comme cela est bien
inspecter voilà la garde républicaine
avec on voit le nombre de rangées de
gardes 1 ce qui signifie qu c'est
vraiment un événement très important
contient autant de garde dans la cour et
voilà elle est ensuite allée dans la
salle des conférences du sénat ali a
prononcé un
un discours devant les parlementaires
alors pas dans l'hémicycle mais donc
dans la salle de conférence devant le
parterre des parlementaires qui étaient
réunis à la voix qui monte le l'escalier
d'honneur du sénat et je vous propose
d'écouter un extrait de son discours
dans la salle des conférences
cet anniversaire donne un sens
particulier à ma visite est à la
quatrième que j'ai effectué en france
ou revenir en arrière il est l'occasion
de célébrer la clairvoyance d'un accord
qui allait jeter les bases d'une
alliance décisive qui aura permis à nos
deux pays le traverser les turbulences
du 20e siècle
on se tourner vers l'avenir
il nous donne à la fois l'occasion de
remises et les tensions nous avons
connus récemment
et de répondre aux défis et aux
promesses on sera fait demain
voilà vous voyez le français impeccable
effectivement vous le lisiez elle
parlait très bien français l'avaient
appris le français avec sa nourrice qui
était d'origine belge dès la plus tendre
enfance elle parle de tension dans son
discours les tensions en question et
bien c'est le nom à l'époque des de la
france à la guerre en irak alors plus
inattendu devant ce parterre de députés
et de sénateurs elle a loué le rôle du
parlement et coûte un deuxième extrait
notre attachement mutuel à la démocratie
parlementaire et le socle de notre
liberté et de nos valeurs communes
la liberté est le bien le plus précieux
que nous ayons or elle n'est jamais
acquise
les liens que nos deux parlements
entretiennent de longue date
non il appelait pêcheurs ni le périmètre
les deux parties souhaitons leur donner
les palmes on continue de jouer un rôle
immense
non seulement à l'échelle nationale mais
aussi dans l'édification de l'europe
demain voilà c'était en 2004 il y aura
eu encore une dernière visite d'état en
2014 et on le sert la france était au
final le pays étrangers où elle a
réalisé le plus de visites merci quand
un atout évidemment vous revenez
à mes côtés dans quelques instants
est-ce que vous qui vise présider ce
groupe d'amitié france royaume-uni sénat
céline boulay ce dernier le décès de la
reine elizabeth ça peut changer quelque
chose dans les relations entre la france
et le royaume uni alors juste pour
revenir sur ce que je viens d'entendre
c'est un peu prémonitoire puisque elle
rappelle le rôle essentiel du parlement
que nous allons vivre plus que jamais
faut-il rappeler à notre président de la
république dans les prochaines semaines
donc on voit aussi les manuels mâcon
d'écouté discours absolument voulait
rediffusera est ce que votre question
portait sur est-ce que ce décès ça peut
changer quelque chose dans les relations
entre la france et le royaume-uni ont le
rappeler c'est vrai que c'est le pays
qu'elles à laquelle a le plus visité
elle parle et impeccablement français il
y avait un vrai attachement de la reine
à la france oui il ya un attachement
aussi de charles qui est devenu charles
iii la france mais est ce que ce décès
peut changer quelque chose bien sûr non
mais comme comme vous le dites on va
voir maintenant si charles iii de god
save the king j'ai envie de dire va
poursuivre l'action de la reine mais il
a eu tellement de temps pour se préparer
à ses côtés je ne doute pas que du point
de vue de la diplomatie en tout cas ils
continuent cette action et continue les
bonnes relations qu'il a avec la france
je crois qu'il aime beaucoup la france
lui aussi je ne sais pas s'ils parlent
français pas à ma connaissance un petit
peu je crois mais je ne je n'en pouvais
je n'ai oublié il y avait là des
francophiles charles qui pour vous avez
pas d'inquiétude les recherches beaucoup
d'inquiétude évidemment le breakbeat
complique tout on a vu les difficultés
autour de la pêche autour des
importations autour d'un certain nombre
de choses cela dit la reine n'est plus
il faut maintenant faire confiance à
charles iii pour continuer cette action
et je suis d'un naturel optimiste
c'est surtout au peuple britannique que
je pense aujourd'hui parce qu'avec la
crise qu'ils traversent j'ai peur qu'ils
rentrent dans une espèce d'inquiétude et
cette disparition la reine n'aidera pas
voilà donc on espère que le nouveau roi
soit aussi solide que sa défunte mère et
c'est tout le bien que je souhaite au
peuple britannique et j'aimerais me
tourner vers l'avenir pour eux je les
aime vraiment et je leur souhaite tout
milliards et on va parler dans quelques
zones de l'avenir du peuple britannique
mais un mot sur ses relations france
royaume-uni avec vous olivier cadic vous
emmanuel mâcon bien évidemment a réagi
de la reine elizabeth il salue en elle
une amie de la france est ce que il faut
y voir un écho à la déclaration de la
nouvelle premier ministre néo strauss
qui elle a refusé de dire si manuel da
cruz est un ami ou un ennemi
juste avant de répondre je voudrais
revenir sur le passage de la reine au
sénat puisque au mas des témoins m'ont
livré une anecdote quand elle est
arrivée devant l'escalier d'honneur et
je vous rappelle qu'à ce moment là il
avait 78 ans et cet escalier d'honneur
qui est quand même très très raide qui
est très impressionnant je crois que les
gens qui accompagnaient la reine n'avait
se sont rendu compte je dirais que
c'était quand même une épreuve qui lui
étaient imposées qui était finalement un
peu inattendu et elle l'a fait avec
beaucoup d'élégance et beaucoup de
naturel c'est pour vous montrer
justement cette capacité en toutes
circonstances de se dépasser ça peut
paraître anodin mais c'est une anectode
kim était revenu que ce qu'ils avaient
vécu avait été vraiment marqué par sa
façon de de s'affronter maintenant
effectivement je pense que le président
de la république sait manier justement
ce les messages je dirais à plusieurs
niveaux il a en exprimant sa de cette
manière évidemment beaucoup y ont lu un
message à la première ministre en
espérant qu'elle serait inspiré par la
proche de la reine d'angleterre celle
qui justement savait être au dessus de
tout never explain mais veut complet
celle qui était capable justement
d'affronter toutes les circonstances et
de d'être rassurante je pense qu'elle va
beaucoup manquer peut-être à la première
ministre elle aurait il est évident que
les chefs d'état enfin des chefs de
gouvernement pouvaient se confier à la
reine avoir son sentiment en sachant p
absolument rien
trans paraîtrait de leurs échanges c'est
je pense que c'est très important pour
un premier ministre chef de gouvernement
de pouvoir avoir ce regard ce miroir cet
appui ça a été d'ailleurs
remarquablement dit par le premier
ministre canadien justin trudeau qui a
expliqué sa relation avec la monarque
qui justement lui donner des conseils et
qu' elle allait lui manquer je crois que
c'est c'est important pour c'était
important pour nous effectivement
pouvoir compter sur sur l'arène pour
faire passer ses messages au premier
ministre il ya eu aussi un symbole quand
elle avait fait son discours au moment
du break site où elle avait fait son
discours en portant une tenue qui avait
des couleurs de l'union européenne là
encore une fois des voeux never explain
mais elle savait aussi peut-être faire
passer des messages subliminaux je pense
que mes tenues vous faites bien devenir
effectivement cette tenue qui ont été
bons pour commenter mais ses tenues elle
servait aussi à faire passer ses
messages politiques
certains l'ont l'ont pris comme ça ceci
étant elle a toujours ce truc l'usmm en
respecter la règle de ne justement
jamais interférer avec la politique
nationale de toujours rester au dessus
d'être le ciment le lien et je crois que
ça a été enfin tout le monde le
reconnaît a été parfaite
céline l'a rappelé pendant cette
décennie 70 ans la fêter ce jubilé ont
été reçus les parlementaires ont été
reçus à l'ambassade du royaume uni pour
pour l'occasion
c'est un règne extrême exceptionnel et
pendant soixante dix ans elle a su tenir
cette ligne et charles iii le prince
charles désormais le roi charles iii lui
succède comme on succède à quelqu'un qui
a régné pendant 70 ans et qui a marqué à
ce point de l'histoire à
le prince charles a le temps ouah
maintenant a eu le temps de se préparer
au contact de sa maman et de ceux
présents à parer à toutes les
éventualités
évidemment il va y avoir une comparaison
elle était tellement populaire mais
c'est son fils il y aura
incontestablement une lune de miel il
passe pour quelqu'un de très intelligent
il sera donc s'adapter y assurer cette
continuité
d'autant que l'histoire ce qui vient
d'arriver va avoir fort à faire c'est la
troisième femme premier ministre de
l'histoire de la grande-bretagne le
monarque qui était une femme disparaît
c'est aussi un symbole le nouveau roi
est donc un homme
élise shubs si elle déçoit les
britanniques dès le début parce qu'elle
est déjà controversé dès le début de son
arrivée au pouvoir ça va être très
difficile pour elle parce qu'il y aura
inévitablement une forme de comparaison
je le pense mais là c'est une période de
7 ans battu ça fait avec le nouveau roi
ouais c'est une période d'incertitudes
qu'il souffre parce qu'on la vit un beau
coup elizabeth ii incarner la stabilité
là dans la même semaine les britanniques
ont une nouvelle première ministre et un
nouveau roi oui est ce que c'est une
période d'incertitude si souvent moyaux
période d'incertitude énorme une triple
crise comme je vous le disais avec une
crise économique qui est majeure donc
c'est une période d'incertitude énorme
je pense que les britanniques même si
c'était inévitable n'avait pas besoin de
cette tristesse la ce moment là et
d'ailleurs il ya l'effet de sidération
parce que quelque part il avait fini par
penser que la reine et est immortel et
il espérait même s'il savait qu'elle
avait des ennuis de santé gagner
quelques mois ce qui aurait permis
d'aplanir peut-être cette période de
difficultés liées à la guerre en ukraine
au contexte international et le fait est
qu'elle disparaît au moment où la
grande-bretagne est en proie à des
difficultés majeures il faut espérer que
tout ça s'améliorera et ce qu'est un bel
avenir au peuple britannique mais en
attendant on est en empathie avec eux
j'allais dire presque au niveau mondial
à la place de la reine qu'il l'a
toujours été il faut peut-être les
soutenir moralement ouais olivier cadic
vous qui évidemment connaissait bien le
royaume uni rappelle ses 25 ans que vous
y habitez est ce que les anglais
accueillent favorablement
charles iii où est-ce qu'ils auraient
préféré que ce soit williams qui succède
directement elizabeth ii on va regarder
la cote de popularité
williams était juste derrière sa grand
mère dans un dernier sondage qui date
d'il ya quelques mois
charles n'est que 7e dans la côte de
popularité est ce que c'est comment il
va être accueilli charles iii par les
anglais
je pense je pense que sa cote de
popularité va monter puisque
naturellement il succède à la reine
je pense que tout le monde l'attend
comme comme roi il n'y a pas de il n'y a
pas de surprise il remplace il
remplaçait la reine dans beaucoup de
cérémonies depuis quelques temps il
tenait le rôle puisque la reine ne
pouvait plus participer j'irai aux
événements comme elle le faisait par le
passé c'est d'ailleurs le prince charles
qui étaient là avec eux emmanuel macron
pour le 80e anniversaire de
comment dire de l'appel du 18 juin donc
je pense que de ce côté là il y aura pas
de problème maintenant le vous savez la
problématique de l'instabilité au
royaume uni qui qui a démarré avec le le
référendum du bord et de sites faut
quand même être conscient que on a eu
depuis 2000 16,4 premier ministre au
royaume uni donc là ça commence à faire
vraiment beaucoup quand on compare à
quinze premiers ministres sur 70 ans
vous voyez un peu la difficulté qu'ont
les britanniques la première ministre
aujourd'hui dit strauss on n'imagine pas
qu'elle va faire un beau mandat comme
premier ministre non plus on sent que la
vraie difficulté au royaume uni
aujourd'hui maintenant c'est de
retrouver une stabilité suite au
référendum du break site de retrouver un
petit peu justement c'est une cohérence
aussi dans la direction et dans les
objectifs on voit que on est dans un
niveau de crise très important avec des
grèves à répétition on sent que
maintenant on rentre dans un un moment
où ça va être très lourd la crise qu
vida je dirais
atténuer le fait que beaucoup les
conséquences du break site maintenant
elles apparaissent
de plus en plus aux britanniques qui
commence à avoir à mesurer l'impact de
la sortie de de l'union européenne donc
aujourd'hui on se retrouve dans une
situation
le président la république l'a très bien
dit en fait le royaume uni est forcément
un allié de la france de l'union
européenne ils vont traverser une crise
il traverse une crise profonde il sait
pas pour autant qu'il faut se détourner
il faut il va falloir continuer à à leur
tendre la main et si eux mêmes ont des
difficultés il faudra être patient
maintenant même parfois pour deux et un
mot de conclusion sur l'avenir
kate middleton et le prince william qui
sont maintenant prince et princesse de
galles sont 2 et 3 auprès des
britanniques dans la popularité camilla
et le roi charles iii ne sont que 7 et 8
ça va être le premier défi ça de charles
de se faire aimer de son peuple ça va
être le premier des filles de toute
façon comme je vous le disais c'est la
stabilité et le sens du devoir au
détriment des ce trajet de stratégie de
communication
si au vu des sondages le prince charles
décidé d'écouter le peuple et de se
destituer au profit de son fils il
mettrait à mal toute sa stratégie qui a
fait le succès de la reine et la
stabilité et le fait qu'elle est
incarner l'unité et le destin du peuple
britannique il a donc intérêt selon moi
5 s'ancrer dans cette tradition on dit
de lui qu'il aime communiquer au
détriment de ce que lui impose la
constitution et qu'il aime parler sur
l'environnement sur d'autres sujets
qu'il est parfois reproché ainsi lui
reprocher parce qu'il peut parler à tort
et à travers
et paradoxalement l'un des succès de la
reine d'angleterre ça a été de ne jamais
parler en public vous savez qu on
reproche souvent trop politiques de
s'exprimer il ne faudrait pas que le
prince charles soit trop dans la rupture
par rapport à ce qu un carnet sa mère
surtout encore une fois un moment le
peuple britannique a besoin de stabilité
et de réassurance merci beaucoup merci
sa vie avec pyrénées d'avoir été avec
nous pour cette édition spéciale c'est
un plaisir de vous avoir sur plateau
merci également olivier cadic d'avoir
été avec nous à distance merci de nous
avoir fait part de votre réaction vous
qui vivez au royaume uni depuis 25 ans
merci à tous les deux d'avoir est avec
nous pas poursuivre cette édition
spéciale consacrée aux décès d'elizabeth
ii une annonce qui a évidemment plongé
le royaume uni le monde entier dans la
tristesse sagna de chair
hier après midi l'inquiétude monte
autour de buckingham palace
l'état de santé de la reine est jugé
inquiétant sa famille se rassemblent à
son chevet les britanniques retiennent
leur souffle et commence à se réunir
devant le palais puis à 19h40 la bbc
annonce officiellement le décès
d'elizabeth deux parkings travail
buckingham palace a annoncé la mort de
sa majesté la reine elizabeth ii d'après
un communiqué du palais la reine est
morte paisiblement à balmoral cet après
midi
le royaume uni est sous le choc il vient
de perdre celle qui a régné plus de
soixante dix ans sur le pays
le symbole de son unité
à londres des milliers de personnes se
rassemblent pour lui rendre hommage
[Musique]
comme s'il avait du mal à croire la
nouvelle des britanniques de tous âges
se presse pour lire la vie officielle de
son décès sur les grilles du palais la
plupart n'ont jamais connu d'autres
chefs d'état elle incarnait la stabilité
du royaume uni qui tourne une longue
page de son histoire
elle était une femme si extraordinaire
une si grande partie de notre pays elle
est tout ce que j'ai connu comme chef
d'état donc ça va être bizarre nous
aurons évidemment un roi pour la
première fois de ma vie charles est la
reine consort camilla j'ai l'impression
qu'elle a mis la barre très haut
elle a vu tous les événements majeurs
que ce pays a traversée elle était là à
travailler jusqu'au dernier jour et
c'est vraiment incroyable cela vous rend
très fier d'être un compatriote de
grande bretagne
un peu plus tard listre snow mais
premier ministre par la reine quelques
jours avant sa mort lui rend à son tour
un hommage solennel et salue son
successeur charles iii fils d'elisabeth
deux nouveaux monarques du pays
aujourd'hui la couronne passe comme elle
le fait depuis plus de mille ans un
autre nouveau monarque notre nouveau
chef d'état sa majesté le roi charles
iii avec la famille du roi nous pleurons
la perte de sa mère et tout en faisant
notre deuil nous devons nous rassembler
en tant que peuple pour le soutenir pour
l'aider à assumer l'incroyable
responsabilité qu'ils portent désormais
pour nous tous à windsor londres
balmoral les grilles croule sous les
bouquets de fleurs les hommages se
prolongent tard dans la soirée et pas
seulement au royaume-uni minute de
silence à l'onu illuminations de
l'empiré state building et du christ
rédempteur de rio extinction des
lumières de la tour eiffel la mémoire
d'elizabeth ii est saluée par les
dirigeants du monde entier et des
citoyens de tous les continents en
france les drapeaux resteront en berne
ce vendredi est le jour des obsèques
d'elizabeth ii et suite de cette édition
spéciale si vous nous rejoignez sur
public sénat édition spéciale consacrée
bien évidemment au décède la bête de
l'angleterre qui s'est éteint hier à
l'âge de 96 ans dans son château de
balmoral en écosse et on va continuer à
en parler évidemment pour la seconde
partie de cette émission j'accueille
frédéric dabi bonjour frédéric merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous directeur
général de l'institut de sondage ifop et
jefferson des sports bonjour devais
faire ça deux jours me large journaliste
à sud ouest et la presse régionale qui
justement valoir titre ce matin sur la
reine d'angleterre la en angleterre qui
s'affiche à la une de tous vos
quotidiens régionaux et durant sept
heures on va poursuivre notre tour des
rédactions de la presse régionale pour
voir quelles relations la reine
entretenait avec les régions françaises
on sera dans le midi dont le centre en
champagne avec vous allez le voir
plusieurs récits sur la manière dont la
reine a marqué nos territoires on verra
également sa content avec vous dans
notre revue de presse à la fin de
l'émission et puis jefferson vous nous
raconterez la reine à bordeaux vous
c'était il ya quelques années c'était ya
quelques années vous ne vous en parlerez
évidemment d'abord une réaction a sondé
ses frais verrez que c'est évidemment
une figure de l'histoire qui disparaît
oui et son couronnement ç'avait été un
événement mondial le premier événement
retransmis en mondiovision si je me
trompe pas et là on voit cette vague
d'émotion pour une personne si lointaine
sa parole était très ritualisé codé si
proche également pour les pré-france
aide a été un véritable repère elle
incarne l'histoire ça a été dit elle a
connu 15 premier ministre anglais dit
président français cette pop c'est
quelqu'un qui s'était une banderole
c'est tout à fait face à aurillac
aprilia et rené coty elle a commis
absolument tous les présidents s'est
elle a fait beaucoup de visite d'état en
france et c'est vrai que ça long sa
longévité son inscription dans
l'histoire dans le temps long créer une
sorte de contrastes incroyable avec
notre court termisme notre système
politique
encore là ce cas d'un public ça système
assez solide mais où les choses peuvent
aller extrêmement vite et c'est vrai
qu'il ya une vague d'émotion il ya bien
sûr pas eu de son âge mais quand on voit
le volume de tweets de postes les
réseaux sociaux quand on voit une forme
de tristesse qui sont parés de notre
pays je prends pas bien sûr de ce qui se
passe en grande-bretagne et m dans le
monde on voit très bien que
ces voix là c'est une géante du xxème
siècle qui s'en va et c'est surtout une
page qui se tourne et c'est
quelqu'un qui a aussi extrêmement
plupart sont sa capacité à être à
distance et moi j'ai en tête sont je
l'avais lu bien sûr son premier discours
elle parlait de servir et c'est vrai que
c'est c'est quelque chose qui a beaucoup
marqué
servir
complètement 70 ans de règne elle n'a
pas abdiqué son fils va prendre le
pouvoir à l'âge de 73 ans donc
effectivement il ya cette continuité
dont parlait frédéric on peut renommer
aussi qui s'impose c'est celui d'unité à
l'incarner à l'unité de la nation
britannique et c'est ce qu'a souligné
emmanuel macron dans son hommage et
l'unité c'est très important chez les
politiques puisque au fond c'est ce que
tout le monde cherche à obtenir dans des
moments de tension y compris en france
c'est un mot aujourd'hui qui s'était
imposé dans le vocabulaire politique on
cherche à avoir l'unité et on voit à
travers ces hommages qui viennent de
partout du monde entier sur pour saluer
la mémoire d'elizabeth ii ce moore
revenir et qui s'imposent et donc
c'était aussi un des traits de caractère
alors y en a beaucoup on a beaucoup
parlé depuis hier soir pour en retenir
deux c'est la fois le protocole
puisqu'il ne fallait pas montrer son
émotion à la tenue se rend parle de
dignité à quand on parle de la reine
elizabeth ii et on pourrait aussi parler
de rock'n'roll parce que alors à
rencontrer tous les grands dirigeants
politiques de ce monde pendant 70 ans
mais là aussi rencontrer tous les
artistes il ya nombreuses photos avec
elle entre marilyn monroe lady gaga les
spice girls l'ours paddington et puis
les jo-2012 avec james bond donc voilà
c'est à la fois c'est deux facettes là
mais toujours dans un rôle d'une dignité
absolue où elle devait incarner à la
fois le royaume uni et le commonwealth
puisqu'à l'été selon l'expression à la
tête d'un royaume t as souveraine du
royaume sur lequel le soleil ne se
couchait jamais donc on a une figure
totalement unique ouais et c'est ça la
fois elizabeth ii s'était ça à la fois
c'était à la fois cette stabilité est en
même temps cette modernité elle a évolué
avec les britanniques oui et avec qui je
retiens ce que vient de dire j'ai
personnes ce côté iconique ou aussi bien
à l'aise avec tout le monde en dix ans
sans retenue vis-à-vis d'elton john 2000
j'ai garé il n'y a qu'à voir les ré les
réactions au delà des chefs d'état au
delà des politiques de ces personnalités
de la pop culture et puis une véritable
résidence alors il ya quasiment jamais
eu de sondages sur elle en france mais
elle a eu une fête peut plus arrêter je
pense au scénith elle a résisté à tout
elle a résisté à la fameuse annus
horribilis où il ya eu voilà entre
le château de windsor de huit sortes de
windsor pardon en flammes il y avait
bien sûr le divorce et la mort de diana
ouais elle a pris la parole sur les
conseils de tony blair il ya eu une
relation spéciale avec deux prémisses
wiston churchill d'à côté tony blair de
l'autre parent et bin ghaith thatcher
pourtant à la première prise pour
l'hermine is pharma fait britannique
mais cette résilience cette capacité à
ne jamais se plaindre être toujours là
et c'est vrai que ça a fini par une
capacité à montrer une ironie sur soi
incroyable et on se souvient de votre
dernière séquence avec l'ours paddington
et j'ai revu hier soir et ça prend une
véritable tout son sens et ça prend
maintenant un un tour extrêmement
émotionnelles
continuer à parler de la reine c'était
évidemment et les chefs d'état vous
l'avais dit à frédéric dont le monde on
sait sont nombreux à réagir on va y
venir avec vous quand on met d'abord on
va commencer par la réaction d' emmanuel
macron un communiqué l'ong communiqué
effectivement publié vers 21 heures hier
soir on sait que le drapeau britannique
a été placée sur le perron de l'elysée
pour l'occasion les drapeaux seront en
berne aujourd'hui est également le jour
des obsèques de la reine a annoncé
l'elysée le communiqué est un qui parle
de la reine elizabeth 2 comme et bien
d'une effectivement une personnalité
hors norme elle se donne à tout entière
à son royaume elle avait en france un
statut spécial dit de également ce
communiqué est dans le coeur des
français une place singulière tout un
paragraphe sur la place effectivement de
la reine pour les français et enfin ce
dernier paragraphe que je voulais vous
lire très solennelle est celle qui
côtoyaient les géants du xxème siècle
sur le chemin de l'histoire s'en est
allé
les rejoindre la république et le peuple
français adresse à sa majesté le roi à
la famille royale au gouvernement de sa
majesté et au peuple britannique le
témoignage son amitié séculaire et de sa
tristesse
merci quand on va continuer évidemment à
voir avec vous les autres réactions a
mis de la france l'amitié entre la
france et le royaume uni c'est ce qu'a
mis hier en exergue emmanuel macron
c'était aussi ça elizabeth ii le symbole
de ces relations france royaume uni bien
sûr vous avez on l'a rappelé les
nombreuses visites d'état de la reine de
la reine elizabeth 2 maintenant ce qui
est intéressant c'est que elle ne
pouvait le diriger pas n'avait pas de
rôle politique en revanche c'était la
femme la plus informés du royaume uni
peut-être que dans les années qui
viennent on en saura un tout petit peu
plus avec des attaques quotidiennes ces
entretiens hebdomadaires qu'elle avait
avec son premier ministre ont frédéric
le rappelait tout à l'heure à les 15
premiers ministres et il y avait ces
entretiens hebdomadaires qui ne fuite
est pas dans la presse le off là pour le
coup n'était jamais révélé on en saura
peut-être un peu plus ce sera
intéressant mais il y avait quand même
on peut supposer qu'ils avaient des
moyens de faire passer des messages avec
les autres membres de la famille royale
aussie qui pouvait intervenir et
peut-être traduire ce que pense l arène
mais au fond il ya un vrai secret autour
de ça malgré le fait qu'elle soit très
très informé donc il ya ces deux aspects
là il ya peut-être un aspect qu'on
connaît un peu moins laissons le temps
faire son oeuvre sur ce sujet là mais
c'était une chef d'état a effectué
effectivement elle l avait pas de rôle
politique dans la constitution mais elle
en avait peut-être dans les faits à
frédéric un des personnes a rappelé elle
était très informés et lé premier
ministre prenait quand même conseil
auprès d'elle même si elle donne l'ordre
de n'est pas d'or dans les rues cette
longévité
absolue elle a accompagné nos vies à
titre personnel et la vie politique
britannique
je pense aussi aux visites d'état en
france aux visites par exemple lorsqu
elle inaugure avec françois mitterrand
le tunnel sous la manche est l acte son
problème que l'angleterre n'est plus une
île de splendide isolement c'est
absolument terminer j'ai vu à plusieurs
reprises des images de sa visite d'état
en france où elle vient au sénat dans un
moment de tension inouïe entre la france
la grande-bretagne s'était pourtant le
100e anniversaire de l'entente du traité
tantôt cordiale de 1904 tension très
forte du fait de la non intervention
française en irak où il ya un bashing
français très fort aux états unis bien
sûr également en grande bretagne elle
est là pour garantir cette unité cette
amitié et c'est vrai alors je suis pas
spécialiste mais oui de fait de
s'entretenir toutes les semaines avec le
premier ministre à faire mon avis que
elle n'est pas restée à mon avis dans
une posture passive bien sûr personne ne
saura des conseils qu'elle a donné je ne
pense pas le même constat de chercher
dans ses mémoires en ai parlé ça reste
du secret absolu mais jusqu'à
personnalités jusque vu son influence vu
aussi sa qualité de garant de l'unité
prothétique elle n'est pas restée dans
une posture big man passive mais on va
continuer évidemment à parler tout ça
mais on va poursuivre le tour de nos
régions puisque je vous le disais la
presse régionale évidemment qui fait
c'est une ce matin sur elizabeth ii on
va aller à montpellier où on retrouve
olivier biscaye bonjour olivier merci
beaucoup bonjour avec nous ce matin
directeur des rédactions du midi libre
évidemment elle a une vie milite ce
matin elizabeth ii reine du siècle oui
elizabeth ii reine du siècle huit pages
spéciales dans laquelle dans lesquels on
revient bien sûr sur la vie de la
souveraine sont son destin ce qu'elle a
laissé à son peuple et au monde comme
vos invités le décrivent sur sur ce
plateau depuis depuis ce matin avec
différentes séquences on a essayé de
donner la parole à tous ceux qui avaient
pu la rencontrer à toutes les personnes
qui ont eu le privilège de la côtoyer je
pense à henry jean servat qui ce matin
signant un très beau papier elizabeth ii
la reine éternel dans laquelle il
raconte et bien cette ascension 7,7
souveraine cette mère aussi cette grand
mère que l'on oublie parfois
qu'il décrit avec beaucoup d'élégance
que je pense aussi à l'interview de
stéphane bern spécialiste évidemment de
la couronne des couronnes et d'elizabeth
ii qui nous qui nous parle de cette
stabilité qu'elle a installé au sein de
son pays
[Musique]
et contre vents et marées tenant à la
fois les racines les les fondamentaux et
la monarchie donc ce sont ces
témoignages qui permettent de mieux
comprendre qu'ils étaient les abbés 2 ce
qu'elle a laissé au monde il y la bête
de cette interview de stéphane bern est
évidemment lire dans midi les mais on le
disait elizabeth ii elle avait un
attachement à la france et des relations
avec ces territoires et ce matin dans le
midi libre il ya également une page que
vous consacrez à la reine en occitanie
oui la reine en occitanie elle est
souvent venu en france elle venait peu
dans le sud de la france elle a eu
cependant que quelques déplacements le
premier c'est en 1972 elle vient en
camargue avec son mari pour pourquoi
mais pour les chevaux tout simplement
parce que elle va rencontrer des
éleveurs des propriétaires qu'elle sera
à avignon où elle sera littéralement
acclamés par la population c'est en 1972
elle reviendra ensuite en occitanie en
midi pyrénées à l'époque c'était en 2004
à tous elle sera reçue par le maire de
l'époque philippe douste blazy ministre
de la santé à l'époque elle rencontrera
évidemment l'ensemble des élus mais
surtout elle ira visiter airbus et par
ailleurs rencontré la foule est là aussi
c'est intéressant parce que nos
journalistes de l'époque racontent
combien ce bain de foule a été
extrêmement intense elle s'est prêtée à
ce jeu parce qu'elle aimait ça c'est ce
que raconte aussi nos lecteurs discuter
avec les commerçants un commerçant qui
lui proposait par exemple du chocolat et
elle raconte moi j'adore le chocolat
merci de cette attention était parti
avec une croix occitane que lui avait
offert un bijoutier donc une relation de
proximité et c'est vraiment le mot qui
revient dans nos huit pages ce matin
l'accessibilité la proximité l'attention
aux autres et ça se traduit dans dans ce
reportage autour de la petite annie on
dit même qu'elle serait venue à
carcassonne à la cité passer une nuit à
l'hôtel de la cité mais nous n'avons pas
plus de garantie donc ça restera un
mystère royal jusqu'au bout merci merci
beaucoup de nous avoir raconté ça c'est
aussi ça qu'on voulait montrer ce matin
dans cette émission c'est la reine
d'angleterre a finalement elle avait un
lien avec toutes les régions françaises
et il ya deux noms de nombreux récits ce
matin dans la presse régionale et merci
olivier nous avoir parlé de la reine en
occitanie on revoit la une de midi libre
reine du siècle c'est à la une de votre
journal elle avait vraiment un lien
effectivement particulier un olivier le
disais c'est à la fois évidemment la
monarque et tout le respect qu'on doit
cette menace mais en même temps elle
était très accessible oui c'est vrai que
c'est intéressant et jefferson façon de
parler de sa visite à bordeaux
peut-être tout à l'heure elle a
rencontré tous les chefs d'état elle
s'est prêtée à des bains de foule c'est
vraiment cette articulation si proche si
lointaine tout le monde peut raconter un
souvenir
télévisuelle en direct de d'elizabeth ii
mais en même temps pas de dialogue
amstrong purge bien sûr pas le moindre
selphy pas le moins éléments de la
nouvelle relation entre les dirigeants
au sens large et la population française
où la population anglaise mais c'est
vrai que avec la france il y avait ce
lien particulier je pense qu'il est née
la guerre il est né de l'attitude de son
père georges 6 pendant que la france
était en fait occupé le fait que général
de gaulle soit parti à londres le fait
qu'elle ait vécu cette guerre qui a fait
contribué à la mort prématurée on le
sait de son père et de ce qu'elle a vécu
les bombardements ils n'ont pas quitté
la famille royale n'a pas quitté londres
le blitz donc c'est vrai que ce cette
communauté de destin tragique entre la
france et la grande-bretagne pendant le
second conflit mondial ont créé un lien
très fort alors que historiquement et
familialement le lien de proximité c'est
entre l'angleterre et l'allemagne
contenu 2d famille royale ouais
jefferson vous qui représentez ici le
journal sud ouest on sait que le sud
ouest c'est particulièrement le cas oui
on va parvenir on peut revenir jusqu'à
votre histoire bien entendu qui était à
la fois reine de france puis reine
d'angleterre évidemment ça crée des
liens tout ça est resté dans la mémoire
vous savez il ya aussi un aéroport à
bergerac en dordogne ce qui fait avec
des liaisons régulières vers
l'angleterre ce qui fait qu'à une
communauté on sait en dordogne très
forte une communauté britannique et puis
aussi des liens avec bordeaux évidemment
je vous refais pas toute l'histoire
comme dont on vient de parler est la
reine d'angleterre était venu en 92 ans
raconte ça sur sudouest.fr ce que c'est
une ville sensuelle
et elle est arrivée à l'aéroport de
mérignac elle a été accueillie par le
maire de l'époque jacques chaban delmas
ils ont circulé dans les rues de
bordeaux en voiture décapotable il ya eu
une soirée sur les bords de la garonne
ou le britannia son yacht était tamar et
elle a dormi sur le britannia et on
raconte tout ça les gens lisent dessus
boss de l'époque avait couvert bien
entendu la visite royale où il avait
fallu faire place nette dans la ville de
bordeaux sortir les voitures on raconte
que la ville avait été nettoyée de fond
en comble ses papiers gras y compris des
prostituées qui avaient aussi écarté
c'est ce qu'on entend dans ce papier de
l'époque voilà donc ça a été un
événement marquant il y avait aussi une
garden party à la mairie de bordeaux
voilà toutes les personnalités étaient
venues c'était un événement ça fait
partie des anecdotes quand vous olivier
biscaye parler de la reine d'angleterre
en occitanie elle est aussi venu en
aquitaine et pour les raisons qu'on a
évoqué tout à l'heure ouais et dans
d'autres régions on verra tout ça on va
retourner évidemment voir la presse
régionale dans quelques instants mais
d'abord content puisque on a vu avec
vous tout à l'heure la réaction d'
emmanuel macron évidemment il ya eu
d'autres réactions dans la classe
politique française ce décès d'elizabeth
ii 1 tout à fait on a vu ce communiqué
de nicolas sarkozy qu'il a publié sur
twitter il parle d'une femme est
souveraine d'exception la reine
elizabeth a consacré sa vie à son pays
au peuple britannique jamais carla et
moi n'oublieront l'accueil qu'avec le
prince philip elle nous avait réservé à
windsor lors de la visite d'état de 2008
écrit l'ancien président autre ancien
président à réagir françois hollande qui
dit adressé aux pas britanniques et qui
a perdu sa reine et met toute sa
solidarité et son soutien la france elle
perd une grande et respecté amis ajoute
l'ancien président il ils disent qu'il
ya aussi cet attachement les français le
lui rendaient bien je garde en mémoire
l'accueil chaleureux qui lui avait été
faite de sa venue en france en 2014
c'est la dernière visite d'état de la
souveraine en france pour le 70e
anniversaire du débarquement un de ceux
que l'on réservé aux personnes entrées
pour toujours dans le coeur des
françaises et des français écrit
françois hollande on continue avec jean
pierre raffarin qui lui parle d'un
profond respect du souvenir d'une grande
classe aristocratique mais aussi d'une
attention aux autres simple et sincère
ça revient ce que vous disiez frédéric
effectivement à cette distance que l'on
doit un monarque mais effectivement
cette proximité également qu'elle
dégageait je voulais vous montrer
également la réaction d'elisabeth baume
l'actuel premier ministre française
j'adresse toutes mes condoléances à la
famille royale et au peuple britannique
il avait 2 fut le témoin d'un siècle
d'espoir et des preuves elle a été et
restera un modèle de courage et un
repère pour plusieurs générations ce
soir les français aussi sont en deuil on
finit avec deux tweets de députés
français marine le pen et qui écrit on
la pensait immortel la reine elizabeth
ii restera à jamais l'une des figures
les plus emblématiques et les plus aimés
de l'histoire de son pays et de notre
continent au peuple britannique mais
plus affectueuses penser enfin je
voulais vous montrer le tweet de fabien
roussel qui bien que communiste et bien
et bien voilà salue l'engagement de la
reine lors de la seconde guerre mondiale
et de churchill aux briques site elle a
tenu son rang écrit-il par delà les
considérations politiques on a vécu avec
elle on ne dira pas vive la reine mais
on éprouve une tristesse sincère et on
voit ces réactions unanimes de la de la
classe politique française avec des
communistes jusqu'en rassemblement
nationale qu'est-ce qu'il faut il voir
dans cette dans cette unanimité c'est la
force d'une monarchie installé légitime
c'est l'affadissement
la disparition de tout clivage et même
dans la vie politique anglaise oui des
clivages une époque très fort entre
conservateurs fait travailler
s'estompait lorsque le sujet était la
reine même il ya eu peut-être le contre
exemple de la disparition la princesse
diana où il ya eu vraiment en septembre
97 où il ya eu vraiment oui peut-être
dans le peuple britannique
une certaine déception sur la froideur
supposée de la reine qui arrive très
vite sont les conseils de tony blair où
il a pris la parole et avec une sorte de
mise en scène très différents c'est à
dire pas de tenues extravagantes
stravagante comment dire en fête colorée
mais en gros plan vraiment on veut y est
quasiment que sa tête où elle a vraiment
dit tout de suite tout de noir vêtu ce
qu'elle pensait de la princesse va dire
hey mais c'est vrai que les règles six
enfants sont particulièrement
intéressantes tout le monde qu'il a
rencontré lors de visites à une anecdote
c'est vrai qu'on ne serait pas
identifiée des différences entre le
tweet de marine le pen se dé président
des anciens présidents de la république
de membres du gouvernement
bref ça peut surprendre cette unanimité
en france assez bien dans la crise
politique que chez les françaises de la
part d'un peuple qui a coupé la tête a
souvent non parce que voilà cette
longévité c'est cette longévité
exceptionnelle et unique qui fait tout
aujourd'hui qui déclenche cette émotion
parce qu'elle a traversé toutes les
époques et tout le monde l'a dit on a
vécu avec elle où elle a vécu avec nous
on sait pas très bien cette confusion et
puis au fond c'est une monarchie quand
même très particulière parce qu'elle n'a
pas de rôle politique donc le le fait
politique la vie politique est organisée
en angleterre frais dès que le rappeler
entre les travaillistes et les
conservateurs les joutes politiques sont
extrêmement sévères et peuvent être
particulièrement rue de la vie politique
n'est pas un long fleuve tranquille en
angleterre ils ont une crise économique
majeure en ce moment on en parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure et que cette
nouvelle première ministre qui arrive
donc l'unanimité qui se dégage la est
liée à un destin unique un destin qui à
surmonter les crises et quand on parle
aujourd'hui d'elizabeth ii on en parle
comme le ciment de la nation britannique
est donc ce terme de ciment veut dire
qu'elle fait le lien comme le dit
frédéric elle dépasse les clivages donc
on n'est plus dans la politique on est
dans autre chose quelque chose qui est
en surplomb qui est vraiment propre à la
culture britannique que l'on ne connaît
pas en france que l'on ne connaît plus
mais parce que c'est un système
politique très particulier avec cette
figure tutélaire qui réunit au bout d'un
moment l'ensemble de la classe
britannique en tout cas le peuple
britannique et après ce qui est assez
marrant c'est qu'on n'en parle aussi
comme des sujets le peuple britannique
et sujets de la reine nous ne sommes pas
les sujets d'un quelconque parti
politique aujourd'hui ou demain qui nous
d'un quelconque président de la
république les français sont des
citoyens les britanniques sont des
sujets à l'égard de lawrence et des
nuances importantes mais au fond c'est
une figure mondiale comme on le disait
tout à l'heure son couronnement avait
été un événement mondial son décès est
un événement planétaire ouais sur le sur
le plan politique on vous le disait elle
incarne cette figure tutélaire
évidemment ce chef cette référence pour
la nation britannique qui après connaît
dette interne ans politique entre
travail et travailler ses conservateurs
mais est ce que quelque part
politiquement elle ne préserve pas les
britanniques peut-être d'une forme de
tentations populistes a sans doute c'est
d'ailleurs géré écouter son discours au
sénat elle parle de l'attachement commun
est réciproque des français et des
britanniques à la démo à la démocratie
parlementaire ne faut pas oublier la
grande bretagne et une main est une fête
monarchie c'est un système parlementaire
nous sommes une république et un système
présidentiel ou parlementaire et c'est
vrai qu'il ya eu des mouvements
d'extrême droite en angleterre mais il
n'y a pas eu cette tentation populiste
même des prises de pouvoir par des
partis populistes comme on l'a connu
dans certains pays d'europe sans doute
oui du fait de cette longévité du fait
de ce ciment du fait de ce référent qu'a
constitué la monarchie britannique
en général je faisais référence à la
guerre on peut faire référence aussi à
l'abdication d'edouard 8 elle n'était
pas du tout sur la liste succession au
trône d'elizabeth et là là là
grande-bretagne a réussi à surmonter ses
crises et sept l'ont cette longévité
agir est enraciné oui ce système de
démocratie parlementaire sur la question
des peuples y ça n'a pas empêché le
break cistes pour autant bien sûr et
lisse trust est une pré une pro bréxent
it vraiment a complètement assumé alors
qu'elle vient plutôt de la gauche à la
était centriste et c'est quand même
évolué dans son parcours politique mais
la présence de la reine est en tout cas
cette autorité morale et cette figure
incontournable n'a pas empêché la grande
bretagne le royaume uni de se détacher
de l'europe alors que dans son règne à
la connu aussi l'arrimage à l'europe
donc à la traversée toutes ces crises là
et elle a vu aussi ce glissement
s'opérer dans la classe politique
britannique oui justement sur la place
du royaume uni dans le monde on va en
parler d'abord on va voir les réactions
à l'international évidemment puisque de
nombreux chefs d'état tu as fait on va
commencer par des pays du commonwealth
puisque c'est logique qu'ils ont été les
premiers à réagir je crois que le tout
premier on le voit c'est justin trudeau
de je crois que c'est lui qui la
première réaction hier soir à
l'international il a parlé du fait que
dans un monde très compliqué sa présence
sa grâce sa force a été une ressource
importante pour nous tous a dit justin
trudeau il est dit c'était une de mes
personnes préféré au monde elle me
manquera énormément
deuxième réaction je voulais vous
montrer toujours un commonwealth et la
première ministre de la nouvelle zélande
alors elle a posé voyait qu'un un
portrait de la reine comme cela à ses
côtés elle a dit c'est un moment de
profonde tristesse pour les plus jeunes
comme les plus âgés il ne fait aucun
doute qu'un chapitre se ferme
aujourd'hui et et avec cela tu nous
exprimons notre gratitude envers une
femme incroyable que nous avons eu la
chance appelé notre reine troisième pays
du commonwealth que je voulais vous
montrer c'est la réaction du premier
ministre australien lui il parle et bien
du fait qu'avec le décès de la reine
elizabeth ii c'est un règne historique
et une longue vie consacrée au devoir et
à la famille à la fois et aux services
qui ont pris fin et il distingue jour de
profonde tristesse et de chagrin pour la
famille royale qui a perdu une mère une
grand mère est une p grand-mère adorée
je voulais continuer avec d'autres
réactions une très symbolique très
importante c'est celle de volodymyr
zelensky aps il a publié un communiqué
voilà il dit au nom du peuple ukrainien
nous adressons nos sincères condoléances
à la famille royale à la somme du
royaume uni au commonwealth pour cette
perte irréparable et est ce qui est tout
à fait étonnant c'est que vladimir
poutine également a réagi lui il a dit
que pendant de nombreuses décennies
elisabeth deux genoux et c'est à juste
titre de l'amour et du respect de ces
sujets ainsi que d'une autorité sur la
scène mondiale a on voit cet argument là
que lui retient les événements les plus
importants de l'histoire récente du
royaume uni sont in extrême
inextricablement liés au nom de sa
majesté et enfin je voulais terminer
avec une dernière réaction parce que les
états unis on a vu l'homme par ailleurs
state building qui s'est illuminé pour
l'occasion et donc je voulais vous
montrer la réaction de joe et jill biden
président des états unis il a dit que
bien nos sentiments nos pensées vont à
la famille et à la reine et au peuple du
royaume uni elle a été le premier
monarque britannique avec lequel les
hommes et les femmes du monde entier ont
pu établir une relation personnelle et
immédiate dernière phrase à la diriger
avec élégance avec un sens inné brand
lab du devoir et à travers le pouvoir
incomparable de l'exemple et on va
revenir évidemment sur ces réactions
mais d'abord un nouveau détour par les
rédactions locales on va à reims ont
rejoint géraldine baer bonjour géraldine
merci beaucoup bonjour avec nous ce
matin on est ravi de vous avoir
rédactrice en chef de l'union et de leur
donner évidemment c'était les apps est
deux qui s'affiche à la une de vos
journaux ce matin oui à la une de nos
journaux c'est la reine de coeur
elizabeth ii qui a laissé hier le monde
orphelin quelque part donc c'était
important pour nous évidemment de
retracer son parcours extraordinaire
cette fille qui a rythmé le 20e siècle
et puis évidemment
au-delà de l'émotion de la suite aussi
qui s'annonce avec charles iii c'était
important de pouvoir rappeler que la
reine un lien de coeur aussi avec notre
région le champagne la champagne pardon
parce qu'elle est évidemment abus
sûrement des milliers des milliers de
coupe de champagne dans sa vie et donc
un lien très fort uni c'est là la
couronne et les maisons de champagne de
notre région page 1 que vous consacrez
ce matin dans vos journaux évidemment à
ce lien une reine qui cultive l amour
des bulles fait le titre exactement
c'est une reine qui cultive l amour des
bulles et les maisons de champagne le
lui rendaient bien
elles ont elles ont suivi évidemment
tout toute sa vie celle de sa famille
également puisque l on était partenaire
de grands événements tels que les
mariage de charles et diana de kate et
william de harry et mégane donc à chaque
fois il ya un peu de champagne à la
table à la table du royaume et c'est une
fierté évidemment pour notre région et
c'est une fierté pour toutes ces maisons
de champagne et tous les to les toutes
les personnes qui travaillent de se dire
que un peu un peu du fruit de ce travail
a traversé la manche pour arriver sur
les tables les plus prestigieuses et est
servi dans les banquiers qui ont vu
défiler les grands de ce monde à moi
parce que je lis dans vos pages serait
moi qui a cuisiné pour elizabeth ii
racontez-nous est exactement alors
c'était en 1977 jean louis le lorrain
qui a eu la lourde tâche ou l'honneur je
ne sais pas ce qu'il faut dire de 2
élaborer le gala pour les 25 ans de
règne de la reine elizabeth et donc elle
avait régalé les convives il avait
régalé les convives
et c'est un souvenir évidemment qui
avait marqué cet homme qui avait fait
toutes ses gammes à reims merci beaucoup
géraldine d'avoir été avec nous on
regarde vos une la une de l'union c'est
la reine de coeur la une de leur donner
un destin extraordinaire évidemment cinq
pages spéciales consacrées à la reine
elizabeth ii dans vos journaux ce matin
merci beaucoup d'être venu nous nous en
parle et géraldine on en revient à ce
qu'on disait ce que disait quentin sur
la place du royaume uni on a vu ses
réactions
de vladimir poutine et de volée de
démarrer l'inscrit d'ailleurs qu'il a
pour le coup ont rendu tous les dommages
à la reine d'angleterre tous les
événements qui dominait en fait
actualité la guerre en ukraine à crise
arrive tout ça est pour l'instant mis à
10 ans très fortement c'est intéressant
de voir la réaction de la dîmière
poutine elle est extrêmement politique
l'autorité
des sujets le fait que est là que l est
lié inextricablement à tous les
événements qu'a connus la grande
bretagne il n'y a pas de réelle n'y a
pas de réaction si je puis dire
émotionnel la réaction de vladimir
inscrits et plus j'irai institutionnel
est beaucoup moins politique peut-être
plus émotionnelle de ce point de ceux de
ce point de vue là on a parlé du du
tweed de joe biden est aussi un tweet
plutôt impeccable de donald trump qui a
rappelé les liens entre la
grande-bretagne et etats-unis elle a
connu tout simplement 13 président j'ai
fait le compte twitter treize président
américain lors de son couronnement
c'était dwight david eisenhower qui
était à la maison blanche ça fait
effectivement est-ce que jefferson la
reine d'angleterre c'est aussi elle qui
a donné sa place
le royaume uni fin l'histoire du royaume
uni dépasse finalement quand même si on
remonte vraiment dans le passé ça me
pose au destin de la reine d'angleterre
maintenant à la
couronnement en 1953
voilà elle a connu le voit rappeler la
guerre la deuxième guerre mondiale son
règne s'achève avec le retour de la
guerre en europe avec la guerre en
ukraine voilà ça montre les
bouleversements qu'elle a pu traverser
maintenant elle a contribué au
rayonnement maintenant le rayonnement
britannique c'est aussi sa puissance
économique c'est aussi ses relations ses
entreprises et c'est donc là le royaume
uni n'était pas figé dans le destin de
la reine c'était un destin en surplomb
qui a accompagné le destin britannique
mais au fond elle a su aussi se mettre
au diapason de toutes ces évolutions
elle n'est pas restée seule enfermée à
buckingham pikine gamme sans regarder ce
qui se passait on le dit tout à l'heure
à lacaune tous les dirigeants politiques
de ce monde mais aussi les artistes les
sportifs les grandes figures donc au
fond elle était totalement résonance
avec avec l'actualité avec le monde qui
l'entouré elle a aussi traversé toutes
ces évolutions est vrai que pareil tout
à l'heure d'icône de la pop culture
c'est aussi ça on pourrait d'ap a parlé
de ses tenues ultra flashy qui faisait
aussi beaucoup le chapeau qui faisait
aussi beaucoup de commentaires mais
c'était aussi sa marque de fabrique
cette espèce de huy d'empreintes qu'elle
a laissée mais après le royaume-uni
s'est fait aussi par ces hommes ces
femmes politiques qui ont fait son
développement oui on vient de voir une
image de la reine avec mikhaïl
gorbatchev en moins de quinze jours deux
géants du 20e siècle sont spontanés
c'est intéressant de voir win le service
minimum je tirais pas en fait médiatique
mais le fait que la mort de mireille de
gorbatchev qui a eu un rôle éminent est
absolument extraordinaire a été quand
même nettement moins si je puis dire
développer que cet événement ça se
comprend très bien ce
qu on est aussi là souhaitons tous
toutes les frasques de la famille royale
qui l'entourent parce que si elle
cultivait un certain sens du secret même
un secret absolu pour ces entretiens
politiques notamment autour d'elle la
famille royale a quand même fait les
choux gras de toute la presse people de
tous les tabloïds anglais on pourrait
parler du prince andrew avec ses
frasques on peut parler aussi de la
famille royale qui s'est déchiré mégane
et harry qui ont renoncé à leurs
fonctions fin bref tout ça alimente la
chronique people et vient aussi
participé du mythe et on va en parler
évidemment tout de suite l'avenir du
royaume uni désormais est d'abord qu'est
ce qu'il va se passer comptant dans ses
prochains jours puisque c'est un
protocole très strict qui est enclenchée
depuis le décès d'elizabeth ii hier oui
tout à fait on sait que ses funérailles
elles sont minutieusement mm elles sont
comme ça préparé depuis des années même
peut-être des décennies
c'est ce qui s'appelle le fameux london
bridge zidane le pont de londres s'est
effondré c15 surnom c'est un stratagème
qui a été créée comme ça pour ne pas
divulguer en avance lorsque la reine ou
le roi était mort et que l'opératrice de
téléphone ne puisse pas savoir que
c'était ça l'info il y avait des surnoms
qui était donné comme ça à ceux à ce
protocole par exemple pour deux genres
de 6 c'était hyde park corner donc voilà
c'est tout un stratagème comme ça qui
est qui est mis en place chaque fois
qu'il ya longtemps oui je te fais c'est
effectivement dans ses références que
que quand on voit que c'est rêve ancien
et alors il ya même un comme ça une
partie du plan qui est spécialement
l'opération licorne puisque la reine
d'angleterre et était en écosse lors de
son décès donc à plusieurs étapes comme
ça pendant les quinze prochains jours
aujourd'hui à leur tour de charles iii
et de camilla et qui était encore à
balmoral ils vont rentrer à londres
ensuite le nouveau roi va rencontrer la
nouvelle première ministre us est qui et
qui avait même rencontré la reine mardi
le gouvernement devrait confirmer la
durée du deuil national probablement 12
à 13 jours
le jour des funérailles sera férié et on
attend aujourd'hui une intervention
télévisée du nouveau roi charles iii
justement la journée de demain elle lui
est consacré beaucoup à lui puisque eh
bien on va avoir un conseil le groupe
des dignitaires qui va proclamer que
charles est devenu roi le parlement fera
également voeu d'allégeance ce sera donc
demain 10 septembre dimanche le cercueil
de la reine et transporté au palais de
holyroodhouse la résidence officielle de
la monarque en écosse lundi ça va
commencer à accélérer le roi avait
quitté londres pour les cosses le pays
de galles et l'irlande du nord et le
cercueil de la reine va être acheminé ce
sera à partir de mardi 13 septembre par
avion a priori nous dit l afp à londres
puis au palais de buckingham
mercredi il y aura cette procession au
centre de londres pour acheminer le
cercueil du palais de buckingham à
westminster la reine qui reposera à
westminster hall pendant quatre ou cinq
jours sur un catafalque drapé de pourpre
le pauvre plus pour s'y recueillir 23
heures sur 24 et là c'est là qu'on
attend des centaines de milliers de
personnes la famille royale qui devrait
aussi venir rendre ma hommage à la
monarque enfin c'est lundi 19 septembre
la date probable des funérailles d'état
à l'abbaye de westminster à londres avec
des dignitaires attendus du monde entier
chez mercier canton voire évidemment
c'est un protocole très mimi tran huy
nom n'a pas connu bien sûr depuis 253
c'est vrai que c'est extrêmement je suis
surpris de voir tout est millimétré
codifier le 19 septembre sera peut-être
la plus grande réunion diplomatique
mondiale de tous les temps
avec la présence à mon avis de tous les
chefs d'états petit vadim yapo signe
peut-être et de vladimir et un ski en
même temps c'est vrai que tout a été
comme vous l'avez très bien dit quentin
tout a été préparé
anticipé depuis maintenant des années
mais on va parler de la suite on va
faire un dernier détour par nos
rédactions locales on va aller dans le
loiret on retrouve alexis marie bonjour
alexis merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
journalistes à la république du centre
et justement puisqu'on a beaucoup parlé
dans cette émission de l'attachement da
la reine d'angleterre ou aux régions
françaises vous allez nous parler de
l'attachement de la reine au centre
oui effectivement à l'échelle du groupe
centre-france de tous les quotidiens la
décision était prise effectivement de
faire notre une et de consacrer nos deux
premières pages à ce décès qui
effectivement dépasse les frontières de
l'angleterre et vient y compris le
toucher les gens du centre de la france
parce qu'effectivement l'image de la
reine dépasse presque l'entendement je
serais tenté de dire et que son décès a
des retentissements vous venez d'en
parler longuement qui sont presque
incroyable pour pour une monarque de
surcroît de par rapport à l'image que
nous on peut renvoyer le notre pays la
france y compris la région centre et on
puisse qu'on va parler de la suite de ce
qui va se passer maintenant élective
vous êtes intéressé aux attentes
vis-à-vis du nouveau roi d'angleterre
charles iii
effectivement l'image renvoyée jusqu'à
présent par le prince charles désormais
le le roi charles iii n'a rien à voir
pour l'instant alors on se parle à ce
que à ce que sa mère a pu a pu faire a
pu dire et donc devant lui il ya plein
de défis qui s'annoncent et
effectivement je pense que le royaume
uni les habitants l'attend de pied ferme
mais quelque part aussi les français
attendent de voir ce nouveau monarque ce
qui devait être en capacité de proposer
et de pouvoir presque substituer à sa
mère dont il doit prendre le relais et
la tâche est immense
merci beaucoup alexis marie et on note
cette très belle une dans les journaux
du groupe centre france est la une de la
république du centre la peine
d'angleterre c'est à la une de vos
journaux aujourd'hui merci alexis marie
d'avoir été avec nous pour nous parler
évidemment de la de la reine
d'angleterre alex il disait les attentes
vis-à-vis de charles iii est ce que
charles iii entame son règne comme un
roi impopulaire non a priori ce qu'on a
pu lire c'est qu'il a pu retirer ce lien
parce qu'en fait il reste marqué par la
sphère de la mort de lady diana dans les
conditions que l'on sait donc ça a
priori ça semble avoir été dépassé ça
fait il est quand même ultra préparer ça
fait des années qu'il est dans l'ombre
de sa mère et qui se prépare à cet
événement là et de son divorce avec
diana avant de la mort d un ménage à
trois exactement donc tout ça est venue
perturber on va dire la trajectoire du
futur russe qui était le futur monarque
maintenant qu'ils aient eu roi
d'angleterre maintenant il ya la
situation de charles iii mais il est
surtout je pense que l'urgence numéro un
c'est d'abord la situation économique la
crise économique en angleterre qui est
sévère qui est majeure li strauss a fait
ses premiers pas à wall street en
annonçant un gel des prix de l'énergie
pour deux ans donc voilà il est on sait
qu'il est laid les britanniques sont
acculés par des factures énergétiques
hors du commun donc extrêmement
exactement donc il ya une urgence qui
est là maintenant là on rentre dans une
autre dimension c'est celle plus de
représentations parce que au fond
charles iii va devoir trouver sa place
mais c'est quand même un rôle très
honorifique même si on a dit tout à
l'heure en début d'émission qu'il y
avait ces entretiens de madère avec le
premier ministre mais néanmoins pour les
britanniques au delà de l'émotion il ya
des rendez vous très important dans les
jours qui viennent pour juguler cette
crise donc ils vont avancer sur ces deux
tableaux le côté émotionnel avec un
nouveau roi qui arrive est une urgence
quotidiennes qu'ils allaient crise
économique une crise économique une
crise sociale est ce qu il peut aussi y
avoir une crise politique dans la même
semaine le royaume uni qui était habitué
à la stabilité se retrouve avec un
nouveau roi une nouvelle première mini
est-ce que ça va être compliqué à gérer
personne ne peut le dire mais c'est vrai
c'est complètement fait inédit comme le
jefferson très bien dit il ya la
coïncidence d'un agenda royal c'est vrai
que les premiers pas de george iii connu
par tous les britanniques mais comme par
définition h chaque parent dont charles
iii je suis sûr montrent un peu loin
jarry 3 archi connu des britanniques
effectivement retisser des liens il a
été trés vilipendé après le divorce
après bien sûr la mort de lady di mais
qui est il assure retisser un lien cet
agenda royal charles iii ses premiers
pas et puis cet agenda politique
économique sociale avec une crise
inflationniste beaucoup plus forte
qu'ici en france en grande en grande
bretagne une une inquiétude très forte
et puis et puis oui boris johnson et
les parties liste rose c'est très peu
connue des britanniques c'est vrai qu'il
ya un climat d'incertitude qui arrivent
mais bon l'anglais la grande bretagne on
a vu d'autres si je puis dire et
les conséquences du bric site qui
commence à se faire sentir pour les
britanniques déjà le bric site a changé
la relation qu'avait les français
vis-à-vis des grande bretagne en avait
fait une enquête pour public sénat
en fait d'ailleurs et la part des
français qui considérait la grande
bretagne comme un allié sûr avait chuté
d'une trentaine de points avant et après
le précité choses ont peut-être changé
mais très clairement on entendait des
voix en france dire que de briques site
était une formidable nouvelles
économiques pour la grande bretagne que
celle ci se porte nettement mieux sur le
plan économique que notre pays on ne les
entend plus c'est complètement démentie
par les faits et c'est vrai qu'il ya une
sorte de montée des périls de choc de
crise protéiforme économique peut-être
sociale politique il est un peu trop tôt
pour le dire mais c'est vrai que le
temps d incertitude arrive dans ce pays
on pourra peut-être faire juste une
remarque c'est que liszt ross n'a pas
été capable de dire si emmanuel macron
abrite un ami ou un ennemi on verra à
cet égard comment le le chat charles iii
le nouveau monarque se positionne sur la
scène internationale peut-être que il
est francophile mais peut-être qu'on
verra là
l'expression peut-être d'une divergence
en tout cas ce sera très intéressant à
regarder parce que l'histoire c'est
attendu sur ce terrain là et le roi
charles iii de force y faire lui aussi
aura ce rôle la fois et on suivra bien
évidemment tous avant de quitter on va
regarder ce qui est à la une de vos
quotidiens régionaux on en a beaucoup
parlé ce matin mais quand on va voir
avec vous d'autres titres puisque vous
avez évidemment épluché la presse on a
entendu des anecdotes avec nos
correspondants vous vous en avez
d'autres qu'est-ce qu'on le disait
évidemment tous les quotidiens régionaux
sont consacrés à elizabeth ii voilà on
va commencer par revoir effectivement
cette très grande unanimité un le signe
du grand retentissement de l'événement
avec de très belles une publiée ce matin
aux quatre coins de la france la dual
arènes écrit courrier picard des titres
en anglais dans le texte ren ren forever
et qui lâcha un clip aux corses aux
longues au revoir écrit le progrès des
unes qui sont l'occasion de voir une
petite partie de l'immense collection de
chapeaux et de toilettes coloré qui
faisait aussi partie du personnage et la
presse quotidienne régionale qui propose
également des cahiers spéciaux dans ses
pages intérieures voilà je voulais
effectivement vous en montrer quelques
uns parce que on les a vus ils sont très
intéressants est nice matin qui titre
sur la fin d'un monde et qui publie donc
dans ses pages intérieures et bien par
exemple l'interview de stéphane bern qui
explique que la reine a accompagné
toutes les évolutions du 20e siècle et
qui raconte effectivement des anecdotes
dans les départements à antibes où vit
un important contingent britannique on
l'a senti une émotion particulière hier
raconte nice matin pour l'une des
anglaises interrogée la reine représente
l honnêteté les bonnes manières so
british ou bien la positivité la
provence superbe une wii avec sept têtes
couronnées et ses mots effectivement sa
majesté vous voyez c'est une très belle
quatre pages où effectivement eh bien on
parle de la reine du siècle une reine
qui a traversé l'histoire le journal
revient aussi sur la visite de la reine
en provence il ya 50 ans du gin tonic
avait été servi déjeuner pour répétitif
raconte aussi un ce voyage de 1972 avec
tous ces détails et effectueront elle
avait été acclamé en avignon c'est donc
à lire dans le journal la provence paris
normandie évidemment beaucoup de pages à
lire ce matin dans paris normandie qui
revient sur les visites en de la reine
dans la région effectivement elle
s'était rendue à rouen également en
1972 on retient cette double page que je
voulais vous montrer quand la reine
d'angleterre débarquer sur nos plages
assez à droite vous le voyez puisqu'elle
a été présente à plusieurs cérémonies du
d'idées comme en 2004 et en 2014 alors
quand elle était aux toilettes bleu
clair c'est en 2004 quand elle est en
anvers et en 2014 mais non qu'elle était
effectivement très admirative de la
normandie à venez visiter aussi et bien
les chevaux en normandie ouais on y voit
je reconnais là votre amant détenus
graphique quentin la dépêche qui titre
sur les 70 ans de raids oui
effectivement mais voilà là encore le
journal est qui revient sur la relation
entre la reine et l'occitanie que vous
avez déjà commencé à évoquer alors j'ai
lu effectivement dans la dépêche une
autre anecdote sur ce déplacement en
1992 quand elles visitent bordeaux
puisque de retour d'une visite d'un
marché elle a eu envie d'une baguette de
pain est leur impasse en bordelais a été
sollicité par un des gorilles de la
reine il s'est précipité pour aller
acheter le croustillant plaisir raconte
le journal et le remettre à l'officier
personne ne m'a remboursé racontera-t-il
des années plus tard
vous lire tout ça sur sudouest.fr ce
qu'on a retrouvé la personne qui a
acheté le baguette de pain qu'ils
livrent ce témoin ni ballard donc
allez-y vous avez sur sudouest.fr vous
aurez toute l'histoire avec les détails
et c'est donc ce soir et tout à l'heure
avec croustillons bien entendu on
découvre le croustillant plaisir
dernier mot avec corse matin bien sûr
vous faire plaisir organes on termine
avec voilà cette superbe une
effectivement de corse matin cet ex est
voilà c'est une queen effectivement
dangereux mal on peut lire que eh bien
elle avait visité la corse en visite
privée c'était en 1956 mais malgré le
fait que c'est une visite privée le
déplacement avait fuité et elles avaient
été accueillies à ajaccio sous des
poignées de riz et des vivats et on
regarde la une de sud ouest à l'orias
l'anecdote à dire sur ce que devrait
faire la une de sud est ces éternels
quatre pages spéciales à lire dans le
journal de ce matin qui revient sur le
vienne sur le destin hors norme de la
reine elizabeth ii est aussi les
conséquences et suit avec l'avènement de
charles iii merci beaucoup d'affaires
s'adresse par des recettes avec no mercy
frédéric dabi et à très vite évidemment
dans cette émission merci
quentin de m'avoir accompagné pour c'est
pour cette édition spéciale on voulait
évidemment vous vous parlez de la reine
d'angleterre un peu différemment à
travers nos régions vous l'avez vu à
travers la presse régionale cet
attachement des régions françaises à la
reine d'angleterre et réciproquement
merci à tous de nous avoir suivis pour
cette édition spéciale on se retrouve
lundi très bon week-end
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous en présenter le
club des territoires
[Musique]